so if we obviously look in the cockpit  this is a mixed glass this seat is  actually molded to mix specifically and  he actually makes adjustments to it he  sits in it until it sets around the  thumb and it's nice and cozy it's  obviously like it's so hard you ever go  karting before you'll know you get  bruises on your ribs from rattling  around in the sea especially if you're a  bit Slimmer so his seat is perfectly  contoured to him and padded and even you  can see he's got  he's got any pump up and this is Nick's  steering wheel all the stickers on the  front room so the different modes and  stuff  on the radio we'll be talking about  those different modes you've got your  shifter paddles  foreign  [Music]